- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Ed Talks live,
this new flavor of
homeroom that we're doing.
We have a very exciting
conversation with Brooke Mabry,
about learning loss, summary slide,
and actually our partnership
with NWAEA as well.
Before we jump into that,
I'll give you my standard announcement.
So reminder that we are
philanthropically funded
and we can only do the work we do
through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please go to khanacademy.org/donate
and donations of all levels
make a huge, huge difference.
Every dollar donated to Khan
Academy creates many hundreds
of dollars of social impact.
One of the most scalable
ways that you can create
social impact in the world.
Also I wanna give a special
shout out to corporations
that have stepped up, especially
during the COVID crisis.
Realizing that as the load
on Khan Academy has increased
by a factor of two or three,
our costs have as well.
We wanted to accelerate a
bunch of programs to support
parents, teachers, and
students, so special thanks
to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly
and Novartis for stepping up
and helping us fill this gap.
But once again, we still need help,
especially as we go into
2021 to fill that gap.
Last but not least remind
everyone that there's a version
of this live stream that
you can get in podcast form.
Homeroom with Sal, The
Podcast, so check that out
wherever you get your podcasts.
With that said, I'm excited
to introduce Brooke Mabry,
am I pronouncing Mabry as Mabry, or Mabry?
- No you got it right Sal, Mabry.
- Mabry, all right, well,
Brooke thanks for joining us.
You are a Strategic Content
Design Coordinator at NWEA,
and NWEA is one of our closest partners
here at Khan Academy.
But why don't we, for those
folks who don't know what NWEA
is or what a strategic
design coordinator is,
maybe that's a good place to start.
- Absolutely, so NWEA is a nonprofit,
educational organization
that's really grounded
in our mission of partnering
to help all kids learn.
And so we work in all 50
States and 140 plus countries
around the world, providing
assessment solutions
and educational solutions, to really think
about how we can harness student learning
and grow those students as
far forward as possible.
My role in the organization is
on the professional learning
design team, and so my
work is really around
how do we create content
that supports teachers,
helping their students to learn?
How do we help them
use the assessment data
that they get from our
flagship product, map growth,
but also how do we deepen
their formative assessment
practices and their assessment literacy.
So, specifically around strategic content,
that's really our largest partnerships.
We're both involved
together with Clark County
school district and Las Vegas.
And we also work with New
York city public schools
and Chicago public schools.
So, I'm really in there to
help support our consultants
and our teams who partner with
some of our largest districts
across the nation.
- And just to remind, a lot of folks NWEA,
they may or may not know
that, but the administrators
as you just said of the
map growth assessment,
which 20% of all kids in America take.
And if you look, there's
been over 50 efficacy studies
on Khan Academy and most of them
have been using your assessment,
the map growth assessment.
It's a real differentiator,
it's really the first
and still the major assessment
that can measure growth,
so a lot of assessments
just measure where you are,
or are you at grade level,
but this measures where you
are and how much you grew
from one point to another point.
And how does that compare to
how much other people grow?
Which is really valuable because we know
there might be a sixth
grader who started the year
at a fourth grade level and
got to a fifth grade level
and they had a year of growth,
but on a sixth grade assessment,
they might not see a lot.
Likewise, you might have a
sixth grader who starts the year
at seventh grade level and
stays at a seventh grade level.
They'll do great on the
grade level assessment,
but they saw no growth,
which would be a problem.
So that's what's really cool
about the map growth assessment
and why it's so powerful to
use it to measure efficacy
on things like Khan Academy.
And as we just saw in the screenshot,
we have this partnership where
now the map growth assessment
acts as a placement and a diagnostic
for personalized practice on Khan Academy.
This Map Accelerator which we're
doing with school districts
like Clark County, which is
Las Vegas and many others.
Many hundreds of thousands
of students are now using
this inside of their classroom,
in conjunction with their teachers.
And it's what's connecting the assessment,
the assessment helps figure
out what you need to work on,
on Khan Academy and then,
because everything is linked,
you can figure out how
much that Khan Academy work
has driven hopefully, and we expect better
than expected growth.
So it's a really exciting partnership
that we're doing together.
So, you know, we're in very
unusual circumstances right now,
I think what's is what month,
eight or nine of COVID.
And I know NWEA has been
studying what the effect of COVID
has been or what it could be,
and also how people
have been transitioning
or not to distance learning.
What have you been seeing
both on the research side,
in terms of how it's
affecting students performance
and other ways that
people are trying to cope?
- Well, if you've read
our latest research brief,
we're cautiously optimistic
about what we found.
We made some projections
back in the spring
based on our summer learning loss data
that we have accumulated over the years.
But when we looked at this
fall data and really compared
what was happening, we didn't
quite see the same slides
that we projected and
that's really good news.
Reading was around typical
of where we typically see
students coming in the fall,
we did see five to 10
percentile points of a drop
in the mass area, but it's
not as deep as we thought
it would be, so we really
want to give a shout out
to teachers and say, you really stepped up
and you really adapted well
and found ways to lean in
and make sure that that
loss was not as large
as we thought it might be.
So, that's the initial results,
but we do still have some places
where we don't fully
understand what's happening
in the data, because there
are missing students.
We do have about a quarter of students
that are typically represented
in our data, not there.
And what we have found
is those are our students
who come from the most
underserved communities,
students who tend to be students who live
in impoverished areas,
students who tended to
start at a lower percentile
to begin with and our students of color.
So, we don't have any real conclusions,
it's too early right now
to make any conclusions
in that area, but we do wanna say
that right now we're seeing some positives
and some things to hang our hope on,
but we also know that we
wanted to understand deeper
what's happening in our
places where students
have tended to be underserved.
- So to make sure I'm understanding
this, what we're seeing,
at least based on the data you're seeing,
the reading loss is not
as much as expected,
if anything, it looks like
your data's showing that kids
are tracking similar to
what they would have done
in a normal year.
Math, there is a bit of a regression
compared to a normal year, and
then there's a big asterisk
on all of this because
the number of students
that you can assess,
there's been some percentage
of the population, whether it's
five, 10% of the population
that is just not engaging right
now, over distance learning.
And so you couldn't assess them right now,
but there's a lot of reason to believe
that those are the kids that
were already maybe facing
not as fast growth as we would hope.
The fact that they haven't
been engaged in their schools
would argue that there,
they're probably the worst off
in terms of growth of their learning
and they're probably atrophying.
And because that's not in the data,
it might be making the data
seem a little bit less negative
than it might be.
- That is very possible, and
that's absolutely where we're
standing right now and hoping
that we'll have a more
complete dataset as we progress
through the year.
- Are you seeing that?
Are you seeing that there
is five or 10% of students
that have just not been showing up?
Are districts getting
better at finding them
when you do your January
map growth administration,
do you think you're gonna
get more of those kids
in the assessment?
- I think it's that, but it's
also, some of our partners
decided not to test remotely.
They were busy trying to
up-level their remote instruction
and just didn't feel that
they were ready to administer
the test remotely, we had a large turnout
for remote testing, but we
did have fewer districts
who made a choice not to
test their whole district,
but you're right.
There is a percentage
of students out there
who have not been engaged in school
and have not obviously been engaged
in the assessment portion too.
And I think anecdotally, we're
hearing from organizations
that there's a real struggle,
I think the technological
struggle, if you look
at how we've defined interrupted learning
to be about the physical
space, the technological space,
the social emotional, the cognitive,
but that technological divide
is real in our country.
And so I know that, that
is certainly something
that the district that my son belongs to.
I know that I have teacher friends,
who've said that they have difficulty
getting a hold of students
and students have difficulty
accessing internet.
So, I think that there
are a number of things
that are happening that are
preventing those pieces,
but we really have to
lean in and figure out
how we can address those
systemic inequities
in the platforms and tools
that students have access to,
if we're gonna continue
this remote learning.
- Until the census, maybe
the January administration,
at least more schools will
be ready to do this type
of administration, we still
don't know what might happen
with some of the kids who've disengaged,
that's kind of a deeper problem
that everyone is facing right now.
What are the things
outside, you just mentioned,
essentially the digital divide access,
that's a clear issue that
we've talked a lot about
on this forum.
What are the other
things that you're seeing
that are really tough for the
education system right now?
And what are you seeing
that might be categorized
as silver linings?
- I think one of the
challenges that we often hear
from the partners that we work with,
teachers who are in the field
when we're doing our workshops,
is they often talk about the
way the data is structured,
when you're in the physical
space in the classroom,
it is so much easier to be
able to run your small groups
and to be able to bounce around
to the different students
who need you, and when
you're in that virtual space,
it is much more challenging.
And especially when you think
about the kinds of tools
that we have and whether or
not we're teaching whole group
or small group and how
you have that set up
for your students to meet.
So, I think that the
scheduling is one thing
that has certainly presented
a challenge to teachers.
And I think the other piece is engagement,
we're asking our students
and our teachers to engage
in ways that haven't been the norm.
And so there's this comfort
level that we also have
to address, and this school
climate and community,
it's one thing to build
community when you're in person
with all of your learners,
but to build community when
everyone is sitting behind
a screen and trying to
facilitate those connections,
presents a totally different challenge.
And I think the silver lining
there is that what we're
finding is that those
in-person techniques,
work virtually as well with
obviously some modifications.
But the premise of creating
that strong, connected
learning team, is still the same thing
that we wanna go for.
And so that we know that the
foundation of all learning
is strong relationships,
and I'm hearing teachers say
over and over, the return on
investment that I'm getting
for the way that we're
building community and climate
is really paying off and
now I can really dive in
to some of those deeper learning pieces.
- So teachers are really
investing on this,
they're on video conference, whatever,
but they're making sure
that there's time for them
to get to know each other,
build trust between the students
and the teachers and the
students with each other.
And one of the things
that's paying dividends,
which makes a ton of
sense, are you seeing,
pockets of teachers doing
things exceptionally
well right now?
Do you think there's certain
elements of what's going on
right now that we should
try to retain post COVID?
- You know, one of the things
that I think really stands out
is there's been so much
student choice and voice
that I've seen, in my own son's education
as he's been remote for part
of the school year as well.
And when I'm talking to
teachers across the country,
when I'm partnering, so
I think one of the silver
linings here is that education
doesn't have to look the
same that it always has.
And I think we've been given
this opportunity to innovate
and to see things differently,
and to know that perhaps when we come back
to the brick and mortar,
in a more permanent way,
that we can continue to
honor the choice and voice
that we've allowed students to have,
and really empower student directed
and self-regulated learning in
a way that continues to meet
students where they are,
but also gives them that
motivational factor to engage
in ways that maybe they haven't before.
And I think that's the
really exciting piece
that I'm seeing, is that a
lot of teachers are saying,
you know what, we're learning
some really good lessons
about what works for students.
And we wanna make sure that
we wanna capitalize on these,
and continue these
practices when we get back
to what used to be the normal way.
- So there's a sense that,
some of what COVID's done,
is it's maybe unbundled or
personalize the experience
a little bit more, whether
it's the teachers doing it,
or sometimes families
have done it on their own.
And obviously I believe
strongly in this as well,
if we can keep a lot more
of that momentum around
personalizing to the needs of students,
allowing them to fill
in gaps, learn it there.
I know you've written a lot about,
the zone of proximal development,
which is just the idea
that you should be learning
the things that are just
ready for you to learn,
(laughs) not too easy for
you, not too hard, just right.
I'm curious about the assessment,
and I think a lot of folks,
especially people who aren't super deep
in the education world might be confused,
or like there's so many assessments.
We have interim assessments,
which is what a map growth is,
which can measure growth,
you do it three times a year.
Then you have your state assessments,
which are usually done
at the end of the year
and kind of give a sense.
And the state assessments
are oftentimes the things
that are used to measure school
performance and all of that.
One, I'm curious how you
would tell everyone listening,
how did these assessments fit together?
And where do you think
assessment is going to go?
Y'all have been doing
digital administration
of the assessment, well,
it's always been digital,
but you've had to do
distance administration
of the assessment this
year because of COVID.
You think some of that's going to stick?
What assessment going to
look like in five years?
- That's a really great question,
and I think that it's something
that we're constantly thinking about too.
You know, we were one of the
first organizations to ramp up
and offer our partners the
opportunity to assess remotely.
We know how valuable the
assessment is, because as you said,
an interim assessment is
really a snapshot in time.
And I like to think of those,
I used to say Polaroids Sal,
but some of the teachers I'm working with
are getting younger and
younger and younger.
So I have to say like, it's
an Instagram post, right?
So you line up three Instagram
posts and you can look at
changes over time, but
at that snapshot in time,
we can really see where
students ready to learn,
relative to what I'm trying to teach.
And so when you think about map growth
in that interim space,
we're an instructional
readiness assessment,
not a mastery assessment,
which is what your state summatives are.
State summatives are mastery assessments,
when we look at giving a
mastery test to students,
we're looking at them to
get high levels of accuracy.
So as many right, as they
can, because a mastery test
is all about certifying
what you know and can do,
relative to the standards
that are being assessed.
And instructional readiness instrument,
which is what map growth
is, is the opposite of that.
We're actually looking
for every single student
to get about half the items right.
And people, that blows their minds,
they're like, why would you
design a test where students
are only gonna get about 50%? right?
'Cause that's where the zone
of proximal development is,
when we think about
instructional readiness,
what we're really trying
to find is not high levels
of mastery and not low levels
where they have no background knowledge.
We're trying to find that
sweet spot right in the middle,
where they have some background knowledge,
but mastery hasn't emerged yet.
So, we can use that
information to create a plan,
a pathway forward to mastery,
because what we know
from Lev Vygotsky's work,
which is where we got
this idea of the zone
of proximal development, is
that when we teach in that zone,
what we're doing is we're
helping move a student
from where they are closing
that metaphorical gap
between what they can do
and what they can't do yet.
And so with an interim assessment,
we at NWEA have linking studies,
where we looked at a group
of students in a state who've
taken both the state summative
and map growth assessment.
And we do a correlational
study where we can see
if this is how they score on map growth,
how do they tend to score
on the state assessment?
And then we can provide information
to teachers to help them
understand based on a
student's map growth score,
what kind of trajectory
they're on relative
to that state summative.
So in a way, the map
growth interim assessment
becomes a predictor where
I can use that information
to change a student's trajectory.
So, the interim assessment
is such that it helps us
monitor growth, as you said.
But I like to think about how John Hattie
talks about assessment and he says,
we should look at
assessment as information
about our impact and so
if a student is growing,
we really need to figure out
what is it that we're doing
that's helping get that growth
and how can I replicate that
with more and more students?
But if the growth isn't there, why not?
What are those factors that are preventing
the most growth possible forward?
And how can we really get in
there and change up things
before we get to that state summative?
So if you think about a
balanced assessment system,
we need summative assessments
to understand how students
are performing relative to
those grade level expectations.
We need interim assessments
that help us monitor progress
along the way, but it's really
formative assessment practice
that drives our day to day instruction.
And so, that's one thing
that doesn't get spoken about
enough when people talk about in NWEA,
because they're so
familiar with our flagship
product map growth, that they
don't realize how deep we are
in the formative assessment space.
And so that's where we really get in there
and help teachers think about
their instructional practices
and what am I gonna do
with that data that I get
from map growth and my
classroom formative data,
to keep that learning
moving forward every day
between interim assessments,
so it's the macro,
down to the micro.
- What's interesting, I
know we've talked a lot
about this as we're kind
of visioning the future,
you know, you're using
the interim assessment,
just explain to folks why
you actually need kids
to get things wrong, is that
you're zeroing in at adapts.
Let's say they're a sixth grade student,
you might start them at
a fourth grade concept,
if they get it right, you can give 'em
a little harder concept, a little harder.
Maybe you're getting to
more advanced sixth grade
type concept, but then
they get something wrong
and then you give them an easier question
and then they get a few right,
then they get something wrong.
So, you're zeroing in on
exactly where that learning
edge is, that zone of
proximal development.
And that's also what allows
you to measure growth
beyond just one grade
level, and to your point,
there's formative, and you
know, when I first learned
these words, I was like,
wow, there's a lot of types
of assessments, but formative
is really just another way
of saying, assessment in the
spirit of helping you learn
how well the kids are
learning in the moment,
so that the teachers or
whoever else, is trying to,
even the students can better
diagnose what extra can be done
to make sure they're learning it well.
And what's interesting
with the map accelerator
that we're doing together,
obviously use the interim
assessment to figure out
a personalized learning plan
that the student is ready for.
But then while they're practicing
using the map accelerator
on Khan Academy, that actually
also helps the teacher,
inform the teacher on
what they need help in.
So, it is doing some of this
kind of a shorter cycle loop,
and then, every three or four months,
you then get another interim assessment
to understand overall how
much that's been driving
the growth and then you can re-place.
I say that not replace,
re-place students again.
I mean, it's a fascinating
space of where we're going
with assessment, we're getting
a bunch of questions here.
One is well, there's families
that are worried about,
actually there was a question,
I don't know where it went
about parents with students.
There's reports that we're
seeing an unusual number
of kids who are failing this year,
even kids who typically were
getting A's and B's before,
any advice you would have for parents.
And I guess a broader question,
and students and teachers
is how do we keep kids engaged right now?
And how do we keep their motivation high?
So that these types of
things don't happen.
- Boy, what a loaded question Sal.
I have some really strong
feelings about grades
and I think that that's the first question
that you have to ask, what
is that grade measuring?
Is that grade measuring
progress toward mastery
in the subject, or is
it measuring completion
of assignments?
And so really having conversations
about what grades mean
with teachers is I think really important.
And that's the place that
teachers can create clarity
with their students and with the families
that they serve, is to
really help them understand
what a grade means and what
they're trying to collect
and to know, so that's one piece.
But there's the motivational piece,
our students have to understand.
And this is part of that
formative assessment cycle,
what it is that our expectations are.
So what are we aiming for in the learning?
And really give them a
pathway for understanding
where we're going, but also
understanding where they are
relative to where we're trying
to go and then strategies
for closing the gap
between those two things.
And I think when students
are empowered to see
the trajectory, they're
empowered to figure out
where they are, and then they
get the supportive practices
in the classroom, supportive assignments,
scaffolding, if you will.
I've written extensively
about that on our NWEA blog,
Teach, Learn, Grow, then
I think that's where
the motivation comes from.
A lot of learned helplessness
with students comes
when they've tried and
failed, tried and failed
and tried and failed.
And so I like to point back
at the educational system
sometimes and say, I don't wanna say
we have unmotivated learners.
I think that we always
have motivated learners,
they may just not be motivated to do
what we want them to do.
So, we have to really
tap in and ask ourselves,
what are we doing to help
students see their return on
investment to be successful?
Because that learned helplessness happens
when students don't see
that return on investment,
or they failed over and over after trying.
So, it's important to
get early and easy wins,
students have to experience success.
The greatest predictor of
future success is past success,
success breeds success, so
as teachers and as parents,
we have to help our students get a win.
And then they know what
success feels like,
and then they can crave it.
I always like to say, that
chocolate and red wine
are two of my favorite things Sal,
but I never knew to crave those
things until I tried them.
And so the same thing
is true for students,
we have to give them a
little taste of success
before they'll want it on their own.
And we might have to spoonfeed
it for a little while,
and then eventually they're
gonna take the spoon away
and they're gonna feed themselves
because they know what it feels like,
and they know what it takes to achieve it.
- What I love is your statement
about there's no such thing
as unmotivated students,
I hear that all the time.
Oh, this might be good
for motivated students,
but what about all of
these unmotivated students?
Like it's in their DNA or something,
and there's not a person
on the planet who is not,
you know, the video game
industry has figured out
how to motivate people,
there's a lot of things,
and I haven't met a four or five-year-old
who wasn't incredibly
curious and motivated.
You have to fight them off,
they wanna explore everything,
they wanna ask you 10 questions.
You're like, I'm done
answering your questions,
please give me a break,
every four, or five-year-old
in the world, and so what your point is,
is that they can become
demotivated in certain domains.
But once again, it's not their nature,
it's just a kind of a
learned helplessness.
Ideally, that doesn't
happen in the first place,
but there's ways to deprogram
it by giving them some wins.
We have a lab school, Khan Lab School,
and there was a open house
and the perspective parents
are always like, wait, this
is a school without grades.
And I remind them, no, no, we have grades,
we don't call them ABCDF, we could have,
but we call them advanced
mastery, mastery,
approaching mastery, because
they're four mastery.
And the key is, is that
there's always opportunity,
if a student is at approaching mastery,
which you can kind of view
as a B, or even a B minus.
That there's always opportunities
for them to improve it,
so they never get the message
that it's somehow their innate
Bness or Cness of themselves,
but that's just where they are right now.
If you're practicing basketball,
you're a 60% free throw
shooter, it doesn't mean
you're doomed to never be better,
you keep practicing,
get to 80, get to 90%.
So I couldn't agree with that more,
I was just on a CBS
this morning yesterday,
and I was like, Hey, this McKinsey study
about all these kids failing classes.
I was like, the key thing is
we have to give opportunities
for these kids, especially
'cause they're probably failing
it based on this more
completionist mindset,
are they completing
the assignments or not?
We have to give these kids opportunities,
frankly, all kids when we
get back for them to make up
the work and show that they have mastery,
so that it doesn't do the opposite
of what you just described.
- I agree completely, and
I think what we've gotta do
as an educational system
in the United States
is challenge this idea
of the average as well.
For me, I think that zeros are problematic
and I think averages are problematic,
and I think that what we're
really trying to communicate
is mastery, then we
should be thinking about,
then how do our grades reflect mastery?
And there's an interesting
research study out there
that actually shows that the
minute you put a number grade
on something, the learning
stops for students.
So, I always, when I'm
working with teachers,
really encourage them, as long as students
are in the learning cycle,
withhold that number.
Think about what kind
of descriptive feedback,
what kind of actionable
feedback can you provide
that will feed the learning forward.
And how can you make
time in your classroom,
for students to use that feedback?
I hear all the time from teachers,
well, I write tons of
things on kids' papers,
but they don't ever use it.
My question is one, are
you also including a grade
and two, are you making
explicit time for students
to dig in and improve?
And in what ways?
So, if you're out there and
you're struggling as a student,
or you are a parent who has
a child who's struggling,
or you're a teacher who wants to dig in
and think about these things,
that's where it asks you to start.
To really start thinking about,
what is it that I believe
about grades, what is it that I believe
about student learning and
what am I trying to accomplish?
And how can we do that in a
way that empowers the learner
to have more of the locus of
control and how do we empower
the learner to set goals that
matter and are meaningful
and attainable, and then how
can we be a support for that?
And I really think that's
our job as parents,
I think that's our job as teachers,
is to help cultivate these individuals
who will eventually be
empowered and can self-regulate
and can take charge and
have the kinds of futures
that they want for themselves.
- It's a very, very powerful idea.
Well, Brooke these conversations
always go much faster
than I expect, thanks so much for joining.
And I look forward to
going on this journey,
with you and NWEA, because
I think together we can help
a lot of parents, teachers
and students stay in that zone
of proximal development,
understanding what's working,
not working, make sure kids have a chance
to master concepts, not just complete
a few things without mastery.
So, it's really been an honor
to talk to you about this.
- Thank you Sal, I appreciate
the work and I appreciate
the partnership that we have.
- Thank you, well, everyone,
thanks for joining in,
hopefully you enjoyed that conversation.
Some really interesting
things to think about,
actually, I'm gonna think a
little bit about that notion,
as soon as you see the number,
it might in certain
ways, stop some learning.
We might have to modify
some things on Khan Academy,
(laughs) we'll see about that.
We'll see you, tomorrow's
show, we're gonna have
Beth Gonzalez, who's the
assistant superintendent
of Detroit public schools.
And you can imagine there's
a lot of interesting things
to talk about, when
you're talking to folks
who are administrators of
large public school systems
like Detroit, so start
thinking of your questions
and I will see you tomorrow
at 12:00 PM Pacific time,
3:00 PM, Eastern.
(playful music)